[Music]
foreign
it's hard to believe myself
[Music]
they wanna
break
[Music]
two times
[Applause]
[Music]
I wanna see around
sometimes
[Music]
[Applause]
sometimes
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
friends I am so happy and more than a
little bit relieved to finally be
sharing this video with y'all this has
been months months months in the making
I want to say that I started on the
choreography for this back in like maybe
March or April this year uh we did the
video shoot uh back in June and we have
been working so hard to bring you this
performance I really hope you all
enjoyed it I have so many thank yous put
out there into the world first and
foremost to Isaac dahaco who shot the
video and also edited it you are awesome
as well as to dizzy kit who was our
production assistant for the video shoot
both of you are fantastic folks and I
really appreciate you
um also big thanks go out to flow toys
for sponsoring this video not just for
hooking me up with those amazing koi
that I was using in the video but also
for helping out with the production
costs associated with putting it
together if you'd like to grab yourself
a set of those flow mojapoi that I was
using in this video you can do so by
heading on over to the flowtoys site and
using the code drexfactor 82023 that
code works up until the beginning of
September thank you so much to flow toys
for supporting my artistic vision and
process here at y'all Rock
um
also uh big thanks have to go out to the
Friends of the channel big thanks too uh
dark Monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyro Terra light
toys spin balls and Ultra POI for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these amazing companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I've got down in the
description of this video and a special
thanks go out to the non-business friend
of the channel That is Becca peklinen
thank you so very much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission finally
this video would not be possible without
the amazing support of all of these
wonderful folks right here these are my
flow patrons over on patreon they and
the people who sit down in the
description help to make this video and
all the videos on this channel possible
thank you one and all for your very
generous support and if you out there
watching are not currently supporters
but you'd like to become supporters you
can do that by heading on over to
patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards such as all of the
in-progress videos of my working on this
choreography and performance through the
year and doubtless you'll get to see the
in progress videos of the next thing
that I write as well so please go check
that out thank you in advance
and if you'd like to check out some of
my other uh POI performances I will go
ahead and include a playlist that is of
all the different videos of past POI
performances I've done down in the
description as well as up here on screen
if you are watching on YouTube thank you
so much for watching this video I hope
you get out and flow today and get some
major inspiration from this and I'll see
you with a brand new video real soon
take care now and have a good one peace